Trascrizione: Alessia Banka
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Venezia.
Giri con il carretto della spesa,
piove,
carretto in una mano
e ombrello nell'altra:
Già è difficile così.
Suona al telefono, e ti ricordi
che sei senza un avambraccio.
Sono nata così, motivazione sconosciuta:
credo che i filamenti del sacco amniotico
abbiano strozzato il mio braccio
quando era ancora nel grembo materno.
Sono un'infermiera.
Che io abbia scelto la mia professione
per scoprirne di più,
o perché mi hanno detto
che era impossibile?
Più probabile la seconda.
La mattina mi vesto,
mi preparo, devo pettinarmi.
Oggi per fare la coda ci metto 30 secondi,
ma non avete idea di quante ore e ore
ho passato davanti allo specchio
a provare e riprovare,
a pettinarli delicatamente,
a raccoglierli tutti,
a tenderli in egual modo,
ad attorcigliare l'elastico.
Per non parlare di quando ho voluto
imparare a farmi la treccia.
Poi prima di uscire metti le scarpe,
ovviamente con i lacci.
Devi far danzare questi due spaghetti
in un intreccio sensato e solido.
Mia mamma racconta sempre
che quando ero piccola
legavo anche le scarpe
di mio fratello più grande,
che non aveva ancora imparato.
Quando siamo di fronte a una sfida,
siamo più determinati
a raggiungere l'obiettivo.
E la mia vita è tutta una sfida,
è una sfida con me stessa.
La mia benzina è dire a me stessa,
dimostrare a me stessa,
che ce la posso fare.
Mi piace dirmi "Te l'avevo detto,
hai visto che forte che sei?
Fidati di me"
Poi arrivo al lavoro,
metto la divisa e i guanti,
sembra sempre un'impresa.
Ho questa mano rigida
in cui devo infilare le dita una ad una,
e la misura del guanto è essenziale,
e la mano buona non può permettersi
di essere minimamente bagnata,
perché se no fa attrito e spacco tutto.
L'abilità più ambita è l'ora dei prelievi,
perché nessuno lo crede possibile.
Sono lì al letto del paziente,
che mi guarda impaurito:
non perché si sia accorto di me,
ma perché tutti temono il dolore.
E sono lì che devo trasmettere
serenità e sicurezza
quando respiro un'aria di tensione,
neanche stessi operando a cuore aperto.
Ma perché lo vedo lì
sullo stipite della porta
il collega che mi ha inseguito
incuriosito e diffidente;
ma devo rimanere concentrata.
Devo fare tutto secondo
la mia scaletta mentale,
non ho neanche il tempo di apprezzare
la modalità con cui raggiungo
i miei obiettivi.
Sono un Sagittario:
scocco la freccia lontano
e cavalco fino alla meta.
A questo punto,
quale sport pensate possa piacermi,
se non uno estremo?
Arrampicare.
Mi ha affascinato subito,
perché mi ha dato la possibilità
di utilizzare finalmente
tutto il mio corpo,
trasformare la mia debolezza
nella mia forza,
valorizzare e non nascondere.
Prima di provare,
mi ero messa in testa
che fosse impossibile.
Sì, perché riuscendo a fare tutto,
ogni tanto devo ricordarmi
che sono disabile.
Ma quando torni a casa
dopo una gara internazionale,
con la vittoria in tasca,
capisci che i limiti
sono solo dentro di noi.
Ovviamente ho passato anche io
la mia infanzia traumatica,
tra esclusione, pettegolezzi,
vedermi diversa,
vedermi malata, non accettata.
Fuori.
Sì, perché a casa mi ricaricavo
di amore e di accoglienza,
per non parlare del supporto
percepito a tavola
quando toccava a me grattugiare
il formaggio sulla minestra.
Il cercare sempre ciò
che non pareva possibile avere
mi ha donato tenacia.
Vi pare che non mi piaccia perdermi
in lavoretti minuziosi?
Ho sempre cercato
di somigliare agli altri;
e mi ha fatto bene, in realtà.
Ho capito subito che uguali non è meglio,
ma diverso è speciale.
E poi, anche perché ho imparato
a muovermi in due modalità.
Fino a 20 anni, utilizzavo la protesi
tutti i giorni tranne a casa.
E mi è indispensabile per il mio lavoro,
o per vogare alla veneta;
ma ho capito che è solo una parte di me,
che non me la porterò in tomba.
E così, ho provato
a lasciarla a casa più spesso.
All'inizio mi sentivo
a disagio come mai prima.
La paura più grande erano gli sguardi,
quegli occhi addosso
pieni di commiserazione nauseante,
pieni di paura del diverso,
timore dell'ignoto.
Sembrava stessi girando nuda - o peggio,
che fossi un essere malato e contagioso.
Mi nascondevo ancora più di prima.
Finché non mi sono fermata,
mi sono guardata dentro lo specchio,
dalla testa ai piedi,
sono scesa nella profondità dei miei occhi
e mi sono detta: "Guardati. Tu sei così.
Tu sei bellissima così.
Accetta il tuo aspetto.
Apprezza il tuo difetto.
Ascolta la tua forza interiore".
Ogni tanto, abbiamo bisogno
di prendere per mano noi stessi,
parlarci, rassicurarci e incoraggiarci.
E da quel giorno,
gli sguardi sono cambiati.
Ma perché io sono cambiata,
non mi nascondevo più.
Giravo per le strade mostrandomi.
Non li cercavo più, quegli sguardi:
ovvio, morivo di paura,
paura di vederli ancora;
ma non li vedevo, non li cercavo
e forse non c'erano più.
E se ogni tanto ne incrocio
ancora qualcuno, sorrido.
Non posso cambiare la prima impressione,
ma posso cambiare la seconda.
Ma la domanda è: come fai?
Come affronti le situazioni?
Una mia collega mi ha invitato
a provare a vogare alla veneta.
Non avevo mai provato prima.
Bel pomeriggio d'estate,
sole in fronte, brezza estiva.
Ci imbarchiamo in una mascareta,
io, lei e il saggio vogatore.
Mi spiegano la tecnica:
posiziona le gambe così,
prendi il remo così, spingi, etc.
Io ci provo, osservo, ascolto.
Non ho mai amato condividere
le prime esperienze;
ho bisogno di dedicarmi del tempo,
darmi spazio per pensare.
Ho paura di fallire, mi vergogno;
ma soprattutto, devo concentrarmi.
Ascolto i consigli, ma mi confondono.
Ho bisogno di parlare con me stessa,
per trovare la mia soluzione
che sia comoda, efficace, soddisfacente.
Allora torni a casa.
Come è andata la prima lezione di voga?
Mi sono seduta, e ho osservato.
Li ho osservati attentamente:
la posizione del corpo,
il movimento del remo nell'acqua,
la sincronia tra i due,
l'armonia con il paesaggio.
Ma soprattutto,
pongo attenzione ai dettagli:
i polsi, il bacino, i piedi.
Gesti che andrò ad enfatizzare
per sopperire alla mancanza.
Quando devo apprendere qualcosa di nuovo,
risucchio il sapere altrui:
osservo, elaboro, penso,
immagino, analizzo, respiro.
Conosco i miei limiti,
e lavoro per aggirarli.
Vi ho accennato dell'arrampicata,
questo sport conosciuto
un po' per caso, un po' per sfida.
La passione è nata
quando mi sono resa conto
che ciò che pareva impossibile
ai miei stessi occhi
era la chiave di svolta
per esprimere al meglio me stessa.
Arrampicare è un gesto
creativo e mai ripetitivo:
è un movimento fluido
che coinvolge tutto il corpo,
è un gesto naturale, antico, primitivo.
Te lo senti dentro come una danza.
In altri sport, l'allenamento
è la ripetizione infinita
dello stesso movimento;
in parete, ogni volta è diverso.
Ognuno interpreta la salita a suo modo,
è uno sport che richiede
la tua attenzione al cento per cento,
nella precisione,
nella spinta, nel pensiero.
L'allenamento è risolvere i problemi,
è la palestra per risolvere
i problemi della vita,
è la mia quotidianità,
è il mio allenamento.
Il mio limite mi spinge ad essere presente
in ogni momento di vita,
dal lavare i piatti
al tagliarmi le unghie.
La consapevolezza del momento presente
è meditazione:
produce energie positive,
riconnette la mente al corpo,
crea benessere e armonia.
Ognuno di noi ha bisogno di riconnettersi,
osservare le proprie particolarità,
le proprie pietre preziose,
pietre da scovare e da valorizzare
per esprimere al meglio sé stessi.
Quando sei lì, in campo gara,
pensi a te stesso, sei concentrato.
Poi ti guardi intorno,
e vedi i tuoi compagni:
chi in carrozzina,
chi senza una gamba, chi è cieco,
sopravvissuti a disgrazie della vita.
E li trovi carichi, dinamici, entusiasti.
Assapori la forza
con cui superano le loro sfide,
rimani ammaliato dai loro approcci.
Il movimento paralimpico
è una mostra d'arte,
è la traduzione individuale
della sfida con se stessi.
E noi siamo qui per vincere una coppa?
Noi abbiamo già vinto la vita!
Le prime Paralimpiadi
si sono svolte negli anni '60 a Roma,
anche se tutti ricorderanno
solo quelle di Londra 2012.
Mi sono domandata come mai
tutta questa attenzione solo adesso.
L'attrazione deriva da riuscire
a dimostrare la capacità
di affrontare le situazioni
in condizioni non perfette.
Il concetto di perfezione,
al giorno d'oggi, è stravolto.
Non abbiamo bisogno di perfezione:
abbiamo bisogno di vivere con intensità,
di assaporare il calore sulla pelle,
di essere presenti nei momenti di vita,
di fermarci, guardarci intorno, respirare.
Dobbiamo riempirci gli occhi
di quello stupore
che solo i bambini sanno insegnare.
Dobbiamo imparare a vivere
con consapevolezza la quotidianità,
perché solo essa ci permette di fare
cose fuori dall'ordinario,
ci permette di fare,
ed essere, stra-ordinari.
Potrei stare qui sul palco
a elencarvi tutte le vittorie
che ho portato a casa;
ma la mia vittoria è mandarvi a casa
con degli occhi diversi,
con la voglia di conoscervi,
di apprezzarvi, di reinventarvi;
ma soprattutto, di amarvi.
Sono convinta che non basta
prendere di petto le sfide.
Ognuno di noi ha dei limiti
che deve accettare
per aprire nuovi orizzonti,
così che i muri che abbiamo davanti
non solo li superiamo, ma li sfondiamo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)